what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation all right uh I got a clear
just don't have time to clear my throat
that's how busy we are we're gonna watch
Black Mirror season six episode four
today uh I'm excited I'm really enjoying
this season a lot John how are you
feeling I'm good my throat is clear and
I I'm ready for Black Mirror that's what
I'd like to hear my dear ladies and
gentlemen I'm gonna do the usual Spiel
leave a like like that like button as
much as you can also subscribe click
that notification Bell to get notified
about our reaction for the next episode
is up here on the channel that one might
be a tad bit late just looking at what's
upcoming and what uh currently got a
handle here at the channel also full
interaction watch along where you single
but their own copy of Black Mirror is
available for our super sexy rejects our
patreon page thank you to all who have
been joining just for this show alone
but we cover so many things exclusively
over there with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included all full
interaction watch alongs are available
at our patreon page let's swing an
action
[Music]
sorry that's right folks Surrey Cruz
very specific time to set this in yeah
JP I've been sitting here for two hours
but there's no sign of them are you sure
it was him
I'll let you know
holy [__] that's supposed to be Tom
Cruise I think so
oh going back to the gay rumors rumors
[Laughter]
only Tom catch is talking like that
hey can I talk to you
I can pay
for those pictures
like five hundred dollars
or is he supposed to be a Tom Cruise
type
oh boy if you're Tom Cruise you'd run at
it yeah chase the car
[Music]
TV's Justin camley enjoys a little
Afternoon Delight it is not Tom Cruise
damn they knew what they were doing yeah
300. family hasn't been on TV in like
four years he was on that VH1 thing and
he offered me 500. whoa fridge
a lot of the Season seems to be about
consumerism yeah I have really delicate
sinuses
and when you fry garlic and ginger it
just makes the whole apartment a little
accurate delicious
yeah I'll open the window Nathan thank
you so much I think I can go to hell
yeah she ought to kill him
whoa
whoa whoa whoa
it's not your fault he was just doing
your job that's all
yeah I know
it's kind of your fault I wanted his
face out there the money and the rest of
it and I don't know he gets sad because
he feels exposed she's dumb and half of
these [__] themselves if we didn't
take their picture
says he's got Sydney Alberti in the back
you know birdie Alberti
it's nice for once to see it from the
perspective of them yes humanize the
paps these hard-working people
yes
ugh I love your steak
you piece of [__]
got exactly what you wanted I got
witnesses
speak it you can hear from my lawyer
I mean you verbally assaulted her yeah
you provoked her dude
[Music]
I was just thinking we might go to the
Czech Republic sometime soon
see my ancestors okay guys that's a wrap
for day two take a side for tomorrow if
you don't have them make sure you check
your car seats for pre-call great job
A.D the worst job that's true anyone who
does it is a piece of crap every HD we
will not explain that joke
we will let people think we don't like
assistant directory yep yep
I was schooled it
wake him happy
Wickham
mushroom Abby
power
ful
oh yeah
not while you're tripping don't do that
into that paper massive
you don't have someone who you could
send out there
[Music]
is a well-shot sequence
yeah
well drive
reverse it
look if I live vicariously through these
characters I'm gonna make the bad
decisions okay you get out you do not
get caught
now we're gonna see how good her acting
really is this is
what did he say
they found man in the road
man they think Hit and Run
are there cameras anywhere near here
a whole week since maybe today star of
The everwear Saga abruptly left the set
of the third installment of the
franchise no one has seen it whoa I'm
not good at confrontation so my
therapist suggested that I use
cue cards
you're the worst roommate oh boy your
share of the rent is late groceries
disappearing from my clearly marked
personal shelf in the fridge I'll get
the money
poor guy
so Beau
you got a minute instead of Paparazzi
usually have to work two jobs so tough
being in this field so tough being a
vulture maybe I respect your decision
thought about that I thought that maybe
you could um help me with something
oh she quit yeah amazing day
she was the best in her field she got
kicked off movie set two weeks ago flew
home and no one's seen her since Nick's
offering 30k for the first photo ever
life-changing money 30k
40. if you catch her looking like a
junkie you could get your own fridge
let me know
this is a moral conundrum
[Music]
oh um I think I have some money in my
purse it's okay
Mr G said while you're against in his
house he's left money to cover
everything oh no Mr G
was found
dead let the trail begin his
good old dial up
you could be a researcher she says yours
is here every week saw her yesterday
really game is a foot
drones come in handy yeah
only lazy day was 20 odd years in the
future
[Music]
[Applause]
the supermassive black hole is symbolic
for her emotion black hole with the
pitious soul
first step is to recognize
that you're not in control of this
is your Guru I've arranged a place that
we could take you private out of town
for just for a few days
it's about getting you through tonight
and then we see
she reminds me of Alicia vikander but
it's not
very inconspicuous
[Music]
foreign
you could do it I'm rooting for you I
felt bad for Maisie she was drugged out
and she killed the man get that photo
cooker
are these open roads in L.A like how it
normally is totally breaks the illusion
I like that shot shows you how close
they actually are
too close
Trevor's not suspicious at all this
person's been behind us since the
neighborhood
there it is yep
let's do this oh [__]
hey
damn it
that's not legal
is there a motel within crawling
distance the only place near here is the
Cedarwood Retreat that's really more
like a rehab place
uh Kyle that's my uncle most Stacy's a
masseuse there he says someone hired the
entire complex for the weekend
damn she just stumbles into all the
right information and she got the Thomas
guide hand you were right I'm immense is
a chef
thumbs up for the pecan pie Jesse we
hate to please I want some damn
just shut up and trust me
it's cool shot
no one's hopping this fence what is this
Jurassic Park
got a T-Rex in there or something no
they're just keeping people like us out
and they got a camera up there they can
see you
is that witty's car
did you tell him no did you no
brick where'd you put it huh underneath
my seat I think of it as an unpaid
informant
it's under the gas tank
that is so messed up it's got to be a
Maisy day right
this was my find yeah I heard of this
place let's find a way I am
no way
well that was easy
it's bad
you still get like 7K
7 250 7250 out of it
four ways
probably more than that a little bit
yeah
74.50
73 quick enough right now
six
No 7 500. it'd be like eight something
seven times four is twenty eight five
times four is twenty so 500 times oh
you're looking at 30k okay yeah it's 30k
for the photo right but 40K if she looks
like a junkie
we're both on the right track
isn't bad like holistic food or some
[__] is even a doctor probably would
just about
she must have been desperate to call him
and
you were here for her to get a cigarette
you're an ISO 100 right now I mean they
have a very special kind of lens open to
2.8 in the middle of the night I don't
know
oh yike
thank you sir oh [__] this is
30 grand
that could be anybody is that a chain
around her neck kinky [__] looks like
Babbage shackles are out for the cold
turkey that's [__] illegal Hector
what you guys are doing is no totally
fine yeah
get that photo
oh [__] oh that is so unsettling yeah no
they've really crossed the line here
guys cut the [__] oh that's so messy
this is mad Grim so much for sexy shots
foreign
guys can you just stop for one for one
yeah Christ you've got a billion shots
they say a lot of [__]
okay we're gonna get you out
you're gonna sacrifice her what the
hell's going on here
you don't understand
oh no don't say the wrong thing right
now
hahaha
[Laughter]
are we about to
Jesus werewolf
yes
[Applause]
I love that this is happening yeah I I
don't know how anyone else responded to
this but I am it's so down here right
now I was about to say this doesn't seem
like the kind of episode where someone
will get killed but I hope these guys
buy it
get him
okay
well that one guy was just so late to
registering what happened
guys get that classic shot get that drag
shot
[Applause]
you have so many on your camera
I agree take the camera
[Music]
oh nice light oh
it's not about frying chicken you know
you're gonna saute it you're going to
bake it you're gonna because you
undercook it and you know
people die
[Laughter]
it's out there they could be coming this
way take a few deep breaths settle down
and explain to me what has happened
I will oh I need to understand this no
no no no no no no no
stay down stay down
there oh no not Jesse
can't pass who's gonna cook perfect
chicken I don't care so this is
massively shifted into another genre
yeah yeah
[Music]
he's still taking the photo
eyes on the prize
no I kind of liked you
oh you shot the other guy
hey
wow
if she's the only Survivor it's gonna
look like she killed Maisie day yeah
do it take it take the treasure
killed
this Show's hilarious
just shoot me
I need some kind of confession though
you know
can I get you on tape telling me to
shoot you
DIY
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh God
oh no this season's having fun with
itself
that's it
Moonlighting professionals yeah
moonlight moonlight it's all
Moonlighting all around so much
Moonlighting so many creatures of the
night colliding yeah that was fun
that was really fun yeah
it feels like a
it's like one of those straightforward
like Punchy like 85 minute horror movies
where you're just like I mean obviously
this is smaller but you know within
proportion you're like yes just lean and
mean
to the point
one big twist that's all you need
again yeah media consumerism seems to be
the topic sure yeah this really seems to
be the topic here yeah and the the
lengths media entertainment and
otherwise will drive us to well past the
brink of humanity we have the exploitive
nature of Our Kind too yeah yeah that's
exactly what Charlie Booker seems to
want to be talking about except for
episode three
which was a meditative Space movie
and grief
but other than that one these other ones
I mean I don't know what the next one's
gonna be but this one I I thought it was
fun this is this is one of those where I
can definitely I I have no idea what the
response is on this one but I can see
people like not liking it it just it
sings like one of those episodes that
feels so out of place for what Black
Mirror is he is because it's such a
super like it doesn't feel science
fiction at all no it is just purely I
mean it was a true crime one but that at
least had more of a technological angle
inside in some element
um this exploded through the lens of
paparazzi haha get that exploring it
through the lens oh my God I was well
done I don't care what anyone says that
was great great that was great use of
vocabulary right there perfect so yeah
exploring through the lens of the
paparazzi I just love the way that
sounds
live in this Loop right here works so
well it does right through what the
paparazzi is yeah right through them
you've seen it through the perspective
of them but then also the physical
analogy of how they use their lens yeah
yes exactly the extension of their
villainy of their desires their greed
yes
really terrific
um
yeah it's not it's a moment of silence
for the joke
this movie's a little I keep calling
these movies they kind of feel that way
yeah this one I thought
um I like how tight and lean and mean it
is I think it could have been a little
bit longer because
actually you know what not screw that it
plays like a b it plays like a well-shot
B movie
like specifically this one like a b
movie especially right down to when
they're all like trapped in the diner
and the way that's all lit yeah 100 like
yeah that's a cop he got the other
customers there you got the cook like in
a movie that probably would have been
like 45 minutes that would be the second
half yeah it would be this bottle
situation where they're just in diner
trying to survive or something like that
yeah because it's like once the reveal
comes around you get like kind of a
medley of tropes then because oh yeah
it's we cut back to the the foggy night
and oh the the victim looks up and
they're the werewolf and that's you know
step one and then yeah we're running
through the woods and we got wolf vision
and then we're holed up in the diner and
you even get like an American like one
of that transformation shot where it's
like profile on her and the teeth are
coming in and she's like mostly covered
in here like that really looks like one
of those shots from American werewolf
and uh it feels like if to me it feels
like From Dusk Till Dawn meets American
Werewolf in London in the sense of how
how they are two separate stories that
merge into one yeah and it would
probably be fun to watch it again to see
what they might allude to theme wise
to compare It From Dusk Till Dawn you
know um the in some people con people
usually say that like oh it's just this
one you know getaway movie with these
bank robbers that then suddenly becomes
a vampire movie out of nowhere and
whenever I re-watch it I don't see it
that way like you can see sort of the
um bloodlust of the characters just
within the humanity of them and then
they have this opening scene where like
someone is set on fire and so they're
establishing certain motifs that feel
like they could be
um they're establishing these certain
motifs that feel like they could be uh
you know vampire
vampire
yeah
vampiric that could feel vampiric and
here I I didn't really pick up on much
like it feels like it could be
werewolf except for the idea of who
these people are during the day and then
what they do
in in the in the shadows or at night you
know what they would they really morph
into and like the uh analogy of our zazi
beats character of someone who's trying
to lead the straight and narrow morally
righteous life uh but who she really
morphs into is like she is the werewolf
herself for it still is this act yeah
like it's in her so I could see that
parallel which is probably what they're
doing
yeah yeah I mean it's like and two I can
imagine
like like you said before it's like I
can sort of imagine this being ranked
low in the season partly too because
it's allegorical content isn't like
super revelatory or super
at least at first glance super deep or
anything it's yeah it's like the
addictions that live within the dark
sides of of humanity are that kind of
werewolf metaphor that are very apparent
within Maisie day but also yeah a
character like zazzy Bates who's trying
to who's clearly conflicted with what
she does but also is like good at it and
determined and and yeah so it's like
that's the dark side that lurks within
that then gets pulled out by the full
moon of opportunity
um yeah it's I think this does work best
as viewed through the lens of an
exploitation flick or something like
that it kind of reminded me of like
watching dog soldiers or something like
that which is again lean mean werewolf
joint and uh and I yeah like I I really
enjoyed this for the immediacy and I
think yeah it's like celebrity addict
blacking out erratic behavior and
totally makes sense for a werewolf
allegory going to the you know secluded
uh Wellness Retreat Center is like such
a well-worn Hollywood Trope that like
it's it's like it's it's a Nifty idea to
me like it's fun it's a little silly but
also in like a clever sort of way where
I'm like yeah like just do directly yeah
like actors struggling uh with both the
public eye and their own demons but also
make those demons personified horror
style oh you know yeah yeah I don't
think it's necessarily getting at
something super heady which is something
that like black mirror I think like
Charlie Brooker said he wanted to again
expand the idea of what that means to be
a Black Mirror episode and I like that
they're doing more horror overtly this
season certainly but I do think like
yeah that's the one thing I guess you
could complain about is like it's not
that deep you know or it's not like
shining a light on something that you're
like oh wow that's true or like you know
I never would have thought of that
um but yeah like stylistically and and
the way that they capture like the
mushroom sequences and then and trade
that you know at least spiritually then
for werewolf Carnage I thought was cool
and complimentary it's really well shot
and I mean aside from the unbelievable
traffic conditions it also just
showcases the beauty of our state which
is nice yeah and I like the presence of
zazi beats a lot I think she's a bait
SASE
I think from from her pronunciation I
think it's supposed to be zazi Bates
zazi Bates yeah well it could be
mistaken I always love her presence uh
no even no matter how minor a role she
might have in something but here she's
the lead and I I love I just love
watching her I think she has a really
great screen presence and so just
enjoying her
and I think this is the one
to where
I think this is the one episode out of
the four we've seen so far
where I could feel the writings
kind of talking at me about them
versus just living in the character
perspective solely
you know what I mean because I think I
think that's what makes us swim that's
what's been making a lot of these
episodes very effective in the Stream
where everyone kind of does that but
yeah but this one yeah you have those
two other guys who are just the absolute
worst you know who are clearly like
message care like if it was just Stussy
Bates and the other guy and her other
buddy like I think you might have like
more grayness to play with or like a
more nuanced sort of thing they didn't
even really do it with zaze Bates his
character they didn't really do it with
her like it was really obvious that she
was gonna take that photo yeah it wasn't
like yeah what what position you in you
know yeah totally there's never any
doubt and there's not really like a
crazy growth so much
yeah don't go back like yeah like don't
seal your face with this Final Act of
you know moral vultureness yeah yeah so
it's kind of it was kind of missing that
little punch but not really I mean I I
just think it was a fun exploitation I
thought this was fun this was really fun
yeah and I don't begrudge this show a
quick tight fun one you know and and
like it it does seem like with it is a
little impersonal with everybody I like
the way it captured uh uh Maisie
whatever her name is um Maisie day
because when we're with her we're with
her in all these intimate situations but
it still feels like you are observing
somebody when you shouldn't be and I
think that works really well I think you
know zazzy Bates has a lot of presence
in The Supporting Cast especially her
buddy I thought had a nice presence the
guy at the diner had nice presents but
you don't really
the the furthest you get to know her is
just like I'm trying to live you know an
honest life but also I need money yeah
because I got problems with my roommate
and I would have preferred a little bit
more of a controversial approach
sure of
should we really be sympathizing with
yeah you know yeah I should really be
seeing this in the view of them because
that wasn't kind of keeping me as a
third party Observer yeah maybe kind of
works because that's what they do yeah
it's it's at least worth a good debate
yeah because I would like the challenge
of of ah should I be in their
perspective because they are awful yeah
and I thought that's kind of what we
were doing in the middle when they're
when they're on the chase because I was
because because they give you enough
with Maisie day to be like
I can sympathize with the position
you're in but also until the reveal
comes around it seems like you've done
something pretty terrible so there's a
good quandary there and then yeah with
zazzy Bates you have her conflict and
then when you mix those two together I
think that's the most emotionally
interesting the episode becomes and then
that all you know gives way to yeah
werewolf thing because they set it up
where
that one person died because of her
exposing so I thought they were gonna
have some type of
character moment there yeah
um
but maybe
I mean it did it at all I mean by the
end it's like in doing what you guys did
I guess maybe I mean a couple people
died here but maybe you helped save lie
I don't know if they couldn't contain
this that the wellness Retreat then uh
you know at least you wiped a werewolf
off the map so not more people will die
yeah it's a little
confused in that sense I guess or just
under kind of developed in that sense
and and yeah I mean you also have that
bit on the street where the guys like
berating and verbally assaulting that
woman and then immediately is like oh
you you can't you're insulting me you
know like there are interesting
questions about this particular world of
the paparazzi that it starts with that
it leads with yeah and then kind of
just uh I guess that just it just allows
those things to be in your Consciousness
and little else beyond that
it's just the conflict of living this
life yeah yeah this is the least thought
provoking one yeah of the four
because even though it's not as silly as
stream Berry uh it's it's still the
least at least chanting with the mind
yeah
um but very enjoyable sure I think plays
to things we like John yeah and I mean
I'm always you know it's I love a good
vampire story I know you do as well but
uh I'm always giddy when something
surprises me with werewolves just
because it's a little bit less trodden
in terms of classic monster territory
yeah it was fun yeah alrighty guys well
what'd you think about this one did you
like it leave your thoughts down below
you can subscribe leave a like check us
out on the patron
and hey let's send this for the patreon
Chris swamoff Chris if there's anyone at
our patreon who I could see being a
werewolf it's definitely you you do too
many good deeds and when you do that
many Good Deeds you know where that
stems from
and that you take that guilt and you
project it in trying to write other
things but you have something Brewing
within you simmering seething waiting to
be Unleashed
because that darkness that you fight
against is really within you and that's
why you're trying to externally shut it
down but we all know we all know there's
a monster within you that's willing to
come out just waiting chomping at the
[__]
for its opportunity to
do good with its werewolf abilities to
kill bad guys we don't get enough
vigilante werewolves by night it's
really hard to control your werewolf
abilities but I can see you just taking
matters into your own hands all these
things you get arrested for and fired
for for trying to do good things I can
see you finally going after these people
who are wrong in our world
by straight up murdering them as a
werewolf as a werehoff Chris wareoff
yeah oh get that on a t-shirt
hair off
Chris whamwolf Chris werewolf there we
go plus a werewolf named Chris how how
mad could you be you know yeah there
goes Chris who's Chris
still helping people
with his teeth and Claws cleaning up
after them of course now
even a stain
Chris thank you for cleaning up this
world one bit at a time
you're one of the good ones Chris
[Music]